we're going to go back and let Pearl I
want to hear um because I I honestly
don't know a lot about the gender pay
Gap either I just learned a lot from
them so I'd love to hear this side yeah
um I think in 2022 any girl that can
plan I'm not talking about race because
that's the first thing people always
bring in I'm talking about female to
male
um I I think in 2022 if you're
complaining about the pay Gap as a woman
you're probably just lazy
um I have never had a problem getting
the same pay as a guy um one issue is
that women don't ask for raises so 60 of
women have never asked for a raise and
they quit before they ask for a raise so
how can we be afraid or how can we be
mad that we don't get paid as much if we
don't ask for for more money
um second thing I would say is that
you know we work less hours so they do
studies where they see how many hours a
girl works and we actually get paid more
when you account for hours worked and
the industries we choose we'll talk
about equal pay when it comes or equal
you know
um they want us to be in like the one
percent and all that stuff but they
never talk about the positions like
plumbers bricklaying
um any of the hard jobs women don't want
to do so we get paid less because we
don't like to do hard jobs or ask for
raises I feel like also women or like
obviously mothers so and I feel like who
gets called when something's wrong with
the kids or something needs to be done
at the house the women usually go take
goes and takes care of that so the like
you said what's wrong with the house no
I'm saying like the men you know if they
do get they like she said men put in
more hours what you said if something's
wrong with the house who gets cold no
you know what I mean like usually your
husband or your man is the provider so
you wouldn't be like oh hey babe can you
leave your providing job to go to the
house and meet with the guys who are
checking the roof you he would send his
wife to do that it's you know it's just
kind of that type of thing yeah I could
see that yeah can I jump on what she
said actually because she brings up a
really good point women actually are not
asking for raises because we've been
conditioned to not
rock the boat we've always been told you
know what stay quiet don't really make
any noise you know like maybe eventually
you'll get a promotion if you're well
behaved you keep your mouth shut and
always do what you're told yeah that's
why it sounds like an excuse to me um
I've always been able to go ask for a
raise if I wanted a raise so I have no
symptoms and that's great I have no
sympathy and I'm not going to blame
society if you're too scared to ask for
a raise um grow a pair ask for a raise
and I agree with you 100 I think that
that should be the attitude for women we
should all be taught to think like a man
to be thinking like okay because that
men have always been told you know what
you deserve that you should ask for that
it's not Society it's gender differences
we're more agreeable
but that's not Society that's innate
because because what they do is they
they take women
um from countries that are more that are
more free and less free and the pay Gap
increases with the more freedom we have
are we talking about corporate jobs I
just want to clarify real quick because
most of the jobs before I was
self-employed I did like Hospitality
like serving jobs and obviously as a
woman in a serving job I make way more
money than the the boy servers yeah and
that's the other thing but I can't
really like debate at the same time
because I'm like now I make my own
prices but before I was making more
money than the men in my job because I
worked hospitality and stuff like that
so yeah and certain industries women
definitely dominant even in like Barber
versus hair salon like women
hairdressers make more money
I think a good way to kind of encourage
women to ask for raises is like for
society when a woman's asking for a
raise learn your worth
when a woman's asking for race don't be
like oh she's being aggressive because
men are praised for doing that oh good
for you man for asking for that raise
for doing that then let's praise women
for the same thing as well they get
Christ all the time again like we're
making generalizations if you ask for a
reason if you get asked for a raise like
honestly nobody's gonna call you
aggressive like it's not just well you
don't know excuses
my mom's co-worker
um she was asking she asked for a raise
about
a few times like more than a few if she
actually got honored her raise like
about I think like three four times but
she's still asking for a raise over and
over like so they did call her
aggressive but
also she did get a raise three times and
she doesn't deserve a raise but she was
caught aggressive for kids they might
call them they might call them men
aggressive too but the men say okay
screw you I'll go get another one I'll
never talk about it again what we don't
hear from the men when they're get when
they get caught aggressive like you said
they'll go find another job yeah like
they're not they're not gonna sit there
whining they just say okay screw this
I'll go to another company and get my
pay I want to give my experience on I
actually made more than a man in a a
sales job that I was at um I was making
17 an hour compared to my guy
counterpart he was making 15 and the
only reason why I was making two dollars
extra an hour was because I spoke
Spanish so I had to do on the phone I
had to speak both English and Spanish on
this job well we I was told very clearly
to never say how much I was getting paid
at this job I was told to keep my mouth
shut don't say anything and they
specifically told me the starting rate
for this job is 15 an hour so I I would
appreciate and I would hope that you
honor code that you don't talk about it
okay months went by I didn't say a word
and it wasn't until you know I slipped I
slipped up I was in you know taking a
break
and
um this guy had been there maybe a year
longer than me and he was still only
making 15. and
um I said oh yeah no it's 17 an hour
that's really good compared to you know
what and it just slipped out right
human error and I kid you not about two
months later I got fired if the conflict
of interest as well because it's just
kind of like yeah you're bilingual but
then it starts he's going to the boss's
office like why is she doing a b and c
and he did and he did and he actually
made a scene about it that I actually
walked away because I felt so
uncomfortable he made me cry in front of
the whole sales floor and he was saying
like how dare you have you know because
you're already showing off with your
Spanish skills so why is it that you
have to actually make more than me when
I because I wasn't gifted I wasn't
blessed to speak two languages why is it
that I have to make less than you and I
was like because I'm actually doing
double the work don't you like why are
you shaming me for a my value B my
experience and and and I cried I cried
in front of everyone because he did that
so publicly and again I tell you two
weeks at two months later they found a
way for me to be let go and that to me
I've always carried that because I was
actually very proud that I was like wow
I'm actually making more than my male
counterparts this is really exciting
like hey guys maybe the pay Gap isn't
real you know that's what I was thinking
and then that happened to me and I was
like wow what a coincidence
but I think that's more like you
disobeyed what they said and I know it's
on accident but like they told you not
to like it's just like they told you
that there would be a consequence if you
did that or they said not to and then
they accept that I accept that 100 that
that was definitely my fault however I
think that there should be so that we
have equality of the workplace why can't
we have open transparency of payments if
we're all doing the same job I hire
people I'd rather not do that okay yeah
I'd rather like I said I feel like
that's a conflict of interest and then
like what happened they were trying to
avoid that scene like everybody knew
obviously you deserved the two dollars
you had your credit from your bosses you
know like you didn't need credit from
your co-worker well that's probably I
feel like that's how as like you know
but I think the problem is people start
to get entitled because they feel like
like exactly what happened in that
situation so if I'm hiring five people
and I know this guy's the most
productive right and I know he deserves
more money or she whoever it is and
let's say I paid them 75 000 a year and
I pay someone else 50. when when they
find out about the Gap the other person
might feel like they're just
disqualified and they might feel like
they do just as much work but I'm the
bot like I'm the boss I see I see who
actually does the most work and that's
why you can't have paid transparency
because you have people that feel like
they're worth more than they are and I
think on that note though wouldn't it be
nice for everyone to know going into the
job okay this person right here actually
is making a little more because they
have an extra skill that I don't have
one why don't I go out and learn that
extra skill so that I can be price
matched with what that other person is
that sounds nice and I think if I was
like like when I was on the other side I
might have agreed but like people just
start to get entitled and even even
though even if they're a whole hell of a
lot less productive like it's night and
day it's like people just have this ego
and it's like you can't even even with
the bad guy like everyone else probably
could have said she deserves more money
she's better but even even when they
have that like that's that's not even
just a guy thing like that's just a
human thing I think also it was the
shock I think for it and this is just me
putting myself in his shoes for for
right now I think it was more the shock
of him learning that I was making and he
was there longer than me yeah and so
that's why I'm saying I think it would
be more fair for everyone on the floor
and everyone in the job to know how much
each person is making so if that if that
happened you probably wouldn't have got
the 17 to start no no that's that's what
I mean because like I'm thinking of it
from the employer's point of view like
if I have this one guy and maybe he's
like mid like a mid employee right so
like he's making 15 an hour and I bring
in this new girl and I'm like oh she's
good she's so much more productive she's
gonna make my life so much easier she
deserves the 17. no matter what he's
still going to feel some type of way
because he's been there longer sure let
me ask you a question you do you believe
that uh men and women's pay should be
equal I absolutely do so why did you say
you were happy when you were making more
than your meal counterparts okay you got
that from the comments I did and that
was a good point and I'm asking you now
I I I'm I I agree okay and here's the
thing I I agree that everyone should be
making the same amount however like I
mentioned I was actually doing double
the work I was actually having to speak
in the Spanish language and the English
language and not only that in my
particular sales in the Spanish Division
I had to actually explain what it was
that I was selling So Not only was I
selling I was also having to describe
what it was that I was selling whereas
in the English Department everyone knows
what a home security system is in the
United States but in other Latin
countries a home security system is
literally the dogs of the house so to
have to explain it so like literally I
had to spend an hour on each phone call
so it was a really exhausting work just
to like talk about that so I yes to
answer your questions I believe that
everyone should be making the same
amount I and and here's another example
they ended up hiring another dude and he
was also making 17 an hour so we were
both doing the same job he was making 17
I was making 17 and he was speaking
Spanish
good well no I I hear I'm going to get
to you in just a second bro so we can
keep doing the same thing but let me
read some questions and everybody get
the likes up let's get 100 engagement
please we got more people we've ever had
watching this is the bomb ass show thank
you all for coming please share it out
to everybody else um we got a question
from Gail
um she says question for ladies if there
is a wage Gap and men are so
misogynistic why aren't more companies
hiring only women if your statement is
true it's profitable to hire just women
hold on why aren't more companies but
you're offering only women why aren't
you said all men are misogynistic though
are you making assumptions Gail now
sorry she said question for you ladies
if there is a wage Gap and men are so
misogynistic why aren't more companies
hiring only women great question we
should hire more women I agree me
personally why not I feel like if I'm
doing more I should be making more
um
I wanted to double back before I
answered this question because I feel
like you know there should be I don't
feel like I don't agree per se it's like
we shouldn't have a wage Gap at all
because
just like she said more women are
getting hired and it's like like I said
we women do make more money she like
Pearl said women do Dominate and there's
women who make way more money than men
do and it's just kind of like at this
point I don't want to say women are like
lazy but I mean if you want to make more
money and you feel I feel like maybe are
instead of our
um priority being the home like maybe it
should be more work if we want to if I
just I don't know how to I don't know
and maybe that's not said right but I'm
gonna steal a comment here from Mary it
says pay should be based on productivity
and skills not just yeah I agree that's
that's a good that's a good story and I
think for the most part it is I think
women just don't want to do like the
most stressful jobs that are that are
worth more money and I can see it in my
company like I pay my recruiter double
what I pay my personal assistant that my
personal assistant tried to be my
recruiter for a week she hated it she
hate she was like you could give me
double the money and I do not give a
[ __ ] like this job's horrible it is I'm
recruiting for pot oh my gosh you know
yeah she knows the struggle and and it's
like women don't want to do stressful
jobs we would rather just like and women
I think are better at like more
organizational stuff so she's really
good at being like a personal assistant
um but unfortunately like one is more
valuable to me than the other yeah and I
worked at a warehouse this year actually
at Target warehouse and I can attest to
that like I do we because the pay Gap
was obviously the men on the side where
they're moving pallets and unloading
trucks they're making like 24 and then
I'm like packing online orders I'm
making
1819 but my back was hurting hips were
hurting I'm like I can't do this long
and then men come home and they're like
it's not horrible I'm like so you're
right like a lot of women don't want to
do manual labor I personally don't want
to do manual labor for too long I will
if I have to but I mean I I was willing
to make 18 instead of 24 so I wasn't
like unloading trucks and I don't
necessarily think it's a bad thing like
when I say when I when I say that when
women are like I'm saying the ones that
are using the pay Gap as an excuse
they're just lazy but like the girls
that actually work hard and are trying
to do stuff they understand why men make
more money yeah and I think just to
clarify I think you're talking about a
specific job with the same skills and
the same kind of like work performance
correct what do you mean like what
you're saying like repeat what you just
said which which part
I think basically she's like they're
asking like you believe that men and
women should make the same if they're
equal in stance correct yeah yeah yeah
I want to make sure that that's weird
I mean I think men and women should be
paid if they do the same job and work
the same amount of hours and ask for
raises the same but unfortunately those
things are not the same they okay here
I'm gonna just do this one question
really quick before we go to you bro uh
question the Pearl as a boss you're also
speaking from a place of entitlement
as a boss I'm speaking from a place of
entitlement how I don't I don't see that
at all man uh she had to work to get to
where she's at uh anybody that's a boss
probably I mean don't get me wrong
there's trust fund babies that start
businesses with their parents money but
a lot of classes work to get that bosses
also have a budget so it's kind of like
you're gonna pay your employees like you
said with the work that they're putting
out you don't have just endless amounts
of money to pay everybody equally and
what they think they deserve like you
said it really goes by obviously if
you're getting paid more the boss behind
the scenes sees the production that
you're you have more production than the
next person my yeah I pay my employees
before I even get paid because YouTube's
like delayed as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible